let's talk about remote work part three
of three
welcome back to another episode of
Udacity career tips my name is Martin
McGovern and today we are answering a
question from you the audience what are
the pros and cons of a remote job this
is a great question
I myself am a remote worker I'm here in
Chicago on my company Udacity is in
California and I can say personally that
there are quite a few pros and quite a
few cons of being a remote employee
really quick I list out three pros and
three cons for you to think about as you
strategize your search Pro number one no
commute at one point in my career I
worked in the suburbs and lived in the
city my commute was a 15 minute walk to
a bus a bus to a train a train to a
shuttle and a shuttle to the door and if
I missed any one of those things or the
train slowly pulled out of the station
while I was running up it would add
hours to my day that was four hours a
day of commuting I will say it's much
nicer to be able to check email while
making your coffee in the morning con
number one merging your space as a
remote worker I have the option of going
downtown to our satellite office working
in a coffee shop or working at home and
with Chicago winters being what they are
I often opt to work from home but that
also means that my work space in my home
space have merged which results in
situations like this where it's late on
a Friday and I've still got all my video
equipment set up making videos for you
now I'm not complaining there's a lot of
flexibility that comes with remote work
but sometimes the two spaces combine and
you can't turn it off Pro number two
quiet work time they say every time that
you get interrupted it takes about a
half hour to get back into your workflow
working from home or working remote
that's something that's a lot easier to
control people won't pop by and you know
interrupt you in the middle of something
that you're working on Kahn number two
it's difficult to maintain relationships
with your co-workers now I've gone out
to California a couple of times in order
to chat with people and meet the team
and it's been great I will say that it
is more difficult to build interpersonal
relationships with coworkers when you're
a remote worker than when you are
actually in the office on a daily weekly
basis and able to have walked by
conversations me in the lunch room go
get boba tea all that great stuff it's
not impossible to maintain those
relationships over the Internet it's
just slightly different and a bit more
difficult Pro number
three freedom this is the big one this
is what most people are looking for when
they're trying to figure out if they can
find a remote job they think I can live
anywhere in the country I can do any of
these things and it's true I moved from
Texas to Chicago and I was free to do so
because it wouldn't actually impact my
work so freedom is definitely something
that comes along with being a remote
worker and can be quite good if you're
able to work it out
Kahn number three accountability when
you're in the office you get to have
much more regular check-ins with your
team and your supervisors but if you're
a remote worker you don't have anyone
micromanaging you and looking over your
shoulder you have to be the one who's
accountable not only to yourself and the
things that you need to get done every
day but accountable in letting people
know what you're working on they can't
see if you're overwhelmed so you need to
take it upon yourself to try extra hard
to communicate and be accountable those
are just a few pros and cons about
remote work and why it may or may not be
for you that wraps up part 3 of our
great LinkedIn question about remote
work you have any other questions that
you'd like us to address in future
videos please ask away in the comments
and we'll be getting to them soon thank
you so much for watching keep an eye out
for next week when we'll be bringing you
another Udacity career tip until then
we're wishing you the best of luck in
your job search